ยินดีต้อนรับกลับสู่ Quantum Computing in Practice นี่คือตอนที่ 6 วันนี้เราจะโฟกัสที่หนึ่งในแอปพลิเคชันโปรดของฉัน
ของคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม นั่นคือการจำลองธรรมชาติ ในตอนนี้เราจะพูดถึงขั้นตอนที่จำเป็น
สำหรับปัญหา quantum dynamics ทุกประเภท ซึ่งเป็นปัญหาของการหาว่าคำอธิบายของ
ระบบควอนตัมเปลี่ยนแปลงตามเวลาอย่างไร เราจะทำสิ่งนี้ในระดับสูงก่อน แล้วดูตัวอย่างเฉพาะและดำเนิน
ไปอย่างละเอียด นั่นคือการทดลอง IBM ปี 2023 ที่แสดงให้เห็น quantum utility สำหรับแรงจูงใจด่วนที่
ต้น หนึ่งในเรื่องราวที่โด่งดังที่สุดที่พวกเราในสาขา quantum computing เล่าซ้ำแล้วซ้ำเล่า
คือเรื่องของ Richard Feynman ที่บรรยายที่ Caltech ในปี 1959 และโดยพื้นฐานแล้ว
ให้แรงจูงใจแก่สาขาทั้งหมดมาหลายทศวรรษ การบรรยายชื่อว่า "There's Plenty of Room at the
Bottom" ชื่อตลก แต่ไอเดียพื้นฐานคือเขากำลังอ้างว่ายังมีฟิสิกส์ที่น่าตื่นเต้นมากมายที่รอค้นพบ
ในระดับจุลภาค
การบรรยายนั้นไม่ได้รับความสนใจมากนักจนถึงทศวรรษ 80s เมื่อเทคโนโลยีพัฒนาขึ้นมาก และ Feynman
ก็ชี้แจงและพัฒนาข้อความของเขาตามเวลา เขากลับมาที่ Caltech ในทศวรรษ 80s และนำเสนองานอีกชิ้นชื่อ
"Simulating Physics with Computers" ซึ่งเขาพูดชัดเจนว่าต้องการพูดถึงความเป็นไปได้ที่จะมี
การจำลองที่แม่นยำ ที่คอมพิวเตอร์จะทำเหมือนกันกับธรรมชาติ
โดยพื้นฐานแล้วสามารถกำจัดการประมาณค่าหยาบของสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นในระดับอะตอมและแทนที่ด้วย
คอมพิวเตอร์ที่เข้าใจและใช้ประโยชน์จากฟิสิกส์ควอนตัม ไม่ใช่แค่จำลองสิ่งที่ธรรมชาติทำ แต่เลียนแบบมัน
ลองนึกถึงกราฟ timeline ที่แสดงในตอนก่อน ที่ปลายด้านหนึ่งมีปัญหาที่ง่ายต่อ
การแก้และไม่ต้องการความเร็วที่ควอนตัมมอบให้ แต่อีกด้านมีปัญหาที่
ยากมากและต้องการ fault tolerant quantum machine ซึ่งเรายังไม่มี
โชคดีที่เราเชื่อว่ามีปัญหาการจำลองค่อนข้างมากที่อยู่ตรงกลาง ซึ่งเป็นพื้นที่ที่
เราทำงานได้ในปัจจุบัน และมีเหตุผลมากมายที่จะตื่นเต้นกับโอกาสนี้ เพราะ
การจำลองธรรมชาติเป็นพื้นฐานของพื้นที่แอปพลิเคชันที่น่าตื่นเต้นมากมาย ขอยกตัวอย่างบางส่วน ถ้าเราสามารถ
จำลองธรรมชาติได้ดีขึ้น เราสามารถเร่งการค้นพบวัสดุใหม่ สร้างยาและยาที่ดีขึ้น หรือ
แม้แต่สำรวจฟิสิกส์ใหม่เบื้องหลัง particle physics หรือ cosmology แต่ก่อนที่คุณหรือฉันหรือใครจะ
พยายามนำ quantum computing ไปใช้ในพื้นที่ที่น่าตื่นเต้นเหล่านี้ ตอนนี้พวกเขาต้องเข้าใจขั้นตอนพื้นฐานใน
เวิร์กโฟลว์ที่ใช้การจำลองทั่วไปก่อน
อย่างแรก คุณต้องระบุระบบควอนตัมที่สนใจ สิ่งนี้จะบอกเกี่ยวกับ Hamiltonian ที่ควบคุมวิวัฒนาการตามเวลา
และคำอธิบายที่มีความหมายของคุณสมบัติเริ่มต้นหรือ state ของมัน
จากนั้นคุณต้องหาวิธีที่เหมาะสมในการทำ time evolution ของ state นี้ เมื่อมีส่วนผสมเหล่านี้แล้ว
ขั้นตอนถัดไปคือการดำเนินการทดลองจริง
โดยทั่วไปจะรวมถึงการ optimize circuit ของ quantum time evolution algorithm การ execute
circuit หรือหลาย circuit บน quantum hardware และ post-processing ผลลัพธ์ ดังนั้น
เราสามารถตั้งชื่อขั้นตอนพื้นฐานที่เกี่ยวข้องในการทดลองการจำลองได้ดังนี้
การระบุ Hamiltonian ของระบบ, Hamiltonian encoding, state preparation, state evolution,
circuit optimization, circuit execution, และ post-processing
แต่นี่เป็นขั้นตอนที่ค่อนข้างละเอียด จำไว้ว่าสี่ขั้นตอนของ Qiskit patterns framework ซึ่งช่วย
เราเข้าใจวิธี implement routine ใน Qiskit ได้แก่ mapping, circuit optimization, circuit execution, และ
post-processing ดังนั้นสี่ขั้นตอนแรกที่นี่จริง ๆ แล้วรวมอยู่ใต้ร่มของ mapping และนั่น
คือเหตุผลที่เราใช้ทั้งตอนพูดถึง stage แรกนี้ และถ้าพลาดกรุณากลับไปดูตอนก่อน
ตอนนี้มาดูว่าขั้นตอนเหล่านี้หมายความว่าอะไรก่อนที่เราจะเริ่มเขียนโค้ด สิ่งพื้นฐานแรกที่เราต้อง
ทำเพื่อรันการทดลองจำลองคือระบุ Hamiltonian ที่อธิบายระบบ บางครั้ง
หรือบ่อยครั้ง สิ่งเหล่านี้เป็นที่รู้จักกันดี บางครั้งเราต้องรวบรวมจากการเข้าใจพลังงาน
ของระบบย่อยขนาดเล็กของระบบทั้งหมด เช่น hi คือ Hamiltonian ที่กระทำกับระบบย่อยหนึ่งในจาก n ของ h
เราต้องสังเกตด้วยว่าระบบประกอบด้วย fermion หรือ boson ถ้าเราจัดการกับอนุภาคมูลฐาน ถัดไป
เราต้อง encode Hamiltonian และแปลมันเป็นคำที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเข้าใจได้ บ่อยครั้ง
Hamiltonian เหล่านี้จะประกอบด้วยอนุภาคมูลฐานหรือระบบ spin ถ้าเรากำลังจำลอง fermion หรือ boson
เราต้องเลือก encoding transformation เช่น Jordan-Wigner หรือ Bravyi-Kitaev การ transform เหล่านี้จะ
บอกวิธีแปลนิยามของ Hamiltonian ที่เขียนในรูปของ component ดั้งเดิม ได้แก่ fermion หรือ
boson เป็น Pauli operator ซึ่งแปลงเป็น gate บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมได้ง่าย เช่น Jordan-Wigner
transformation ที่นิยามที่นี่ให้การ mapping จาก fermion operator ไปยัง Pauli operator ถ้าเราจัดการกับ
ระบบ spin-1/2 ซึ่งพบบ่อยมาก เราก็พร้อมโดยไม่ต้องพูดถึง normalization coefficient ที่เป็นไปได้
และเราไม่จำเป็นต้องใช้ encoding scheme ด้วย เมื่อ encode Hamiltonian ที่ต้องการเข้าสู่ gate set
ของคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม ขั้นตอนสำคัญถัดไปคือการกำหนด initial quantum state ที่เหมาะสมเพื่อเริ่มต้น
การจำลอง State นี้ควรสะท้อนความหมายทางฟิสิกส์หรือ configuration ของ
ระบบที่ศึกษา ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าสนใจสำรวจพลังงาน ground state ของโมเลกุล เราอาจ
เริ่มด้วย Hartree-Fock approximation หรืออีกอย่างที่เตรียมได้ง่ายที่มี overlap มากกับ
ground state จริง การเลือก initial ground state ส่งผลต่อทั้งการ converge ของ variational algorithm
เช่น VQE, variational quantum eigensolver แต่ยังรวมถึงความแม่นยำและประสิทธิภาพของ
time evolution หรือ sampling ใน quantum phase estimation โดยพื้นฐานแล้ว initial state ทำหน้าที่เป็น
จุดเริ่มต้นของการคำนวณ เตรียมเวทีสำหรับดึง observable ที่มีประโยชน์เกี่ยวกับระบบควอนตัม
ที่เราสร้างแบบจำลอง การเตรียม n qubit state ที่ arbitrary ซึ่ง ci คือ computational basis state และ ai คือ
coefficient ของแต่ละ state และ normalization condition 2 n ลบ 1 โดยทั่วไปสามารถเข้าถึงได้โดย
การ initialize state ด้วย operator o โดย starting state จะเป็น all-zero standard basis state มักเขียน
แบบนี้เพื่อความเรียบง่าย โดยทั่วไปต้องการ CNOT gate จำนวนแบบ exponential บ่อยครั้งเรา
สนใจ initial state เฉพาะสำหรับระบบ และการเตรียมมันสามารถ implement ได้ด้วย resource ที่สมเหตุสมผล
Product state เช่น ซึ่ง qubit ไม่มี entanglement กัน ต้องการแค่ single
qubit operation เท่านั้น ตอนนี้เรายังไม่มีโอกาสพูดถึง trotterization
แม้บางคนอาจรู้จักมันแล้ว โดยพื้นฐานแล้ว trotterization เป็นวิธีการคำนวณ matrix exponentiation ที่
ใช้การประมาณค่าเพื่อจัดการกับ exponential nature ของ non-commutative operator เมื่อ operator สองตัวเช่น HA
และ HB ไม่ commute เราต้องใช้เคล็ดลับฉลาดและสลับ apply exponential ของ
e^(iHA) และ e^(iHB) สำหรับจำนวน n
ครั้ง ที่ alternating evolution operator ถูก apply ฉันจะไม่พิสูจน์ที่นี่ แต่จะแชร์ลิงก์
ไปยังการพิสูจน์ง่าย ๆ ที่ดีในคำอธิบาย แต่ข้อความสำคัญคือนี่ Time evolution เป็น
ส่วนสำคัญของ mapping ด้วย Trotterization แบ่ง interaction ต่อเนื่องออกเป็นขั้นตอนแยกที่
implement บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมได้ หลังจาก generate trotterized circuit เราก็เสร็จ
ขั้นตอน mapping แล้ว ตอนนี้เราสามารถไปที่ circuit optimization
เพื่อทำสิ่งนั้น นี่คือสิ่งที่ต้องทำ ต้องมี qubit layout ที่ map virtual qubit ของ
circuit ไปยัง qubit ทางกายภาพบน hardware นี่จำเป็นเพราะ hardware อาจมี topology เฉพาะ
ที่จำกัดการโต้ตอบโดยตรงของ physical qubit ในขณะที่การ implement
quantum circuit มักสมมติว่า qubit ใดก็ตามสามารถโต้ตอบกับ qubit อื่น ๆ ได้ จากนั้นเราต้องใส่
swap gate ตามต้องการเพื่อ route interaction ระหว่าง qubit ที่ไม่ได้เชื่อมต่อ เราต้อง translate
gate ใน circuit ของเราเป็น instruction set architecture หรือ ISA instruction ที่
สามารถ execute บน hardware ได้โดยตรง จากนั้นต้อง optimize circuit เพื่อลด
circuit depth และ gate count ขั้นตอนนี้ยังสามารถทำบน virtual circuit ด้วย Circuit ที่ qubit
ยังไม่ได้ถูก map ไปยัง device topology แต่จำไว้ว่าส่วนมากของสิ่งนี้ทำอัตโนมัติให้คุณใน
Qiskit เราจะเห็นได้อย่างไรในส่วนถัดไปของบรรยายนี้ หลังจากขั้นตอน optimization เราพร้อมรัน
circuit โดยใช้ primitive สำหรับการทดลองจำลองส่วนใหญ่ คุณสนใจเข้าใจการเปลี่ยนแปลง
ของคุณสมบัติบางอย่างของระบบตามเวลา ดังนั้นน่าจะใช้ estimator primitive เพราะมัน
จะให้คุณวัด expectation value ของ observable ที่สอดคล้องกับคุณสมบัติเฉพาะ จากนั้น
เราจะกำหนด option ที่ดีที่สุดสำหรับ estimator ซึ่งสามารถเพิ่มเทคนิค error suppression และ error mitigation ได้ สุดท้าย
รันการทดลอง ขั้นตอนสุดท้ายคือ post-process ข้อมูลทั้งหมด สิ่งนี้ดึง expectation value ที่วัด หรือถ้า
คุณใช้ sampler ก็เป็น sample probability distribution ใน computational basis ถ้าต้องการแค่
expectation value ของ observable ที่สนใจ สามารถดึงโดยตรงจาก estimator
primitive ทั้งแบบ raw และ error mitigated value บ่อยครั้งแล้วจะใช้ expectation value ที่วัดได้
สำหรับการคำนวณอื่น ๆ ที่ไม่ต้องการ quantum computation และสามารถ
คำนวณบนคอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิกได้
ตอนนี้เราจะดูตัวอย่างจริงจากงานวิจัยที่มีอิทธิพลมากที่ IBM เผยแพร่เมื่อสองสามปีที่แล้ว ชื่อว่า
"Evidence for the Utility of Quantum Computing Before Fault Tolerance" งานนี้ที่เราย่อว่า
"the utility paper" กลายเป็นงานวิจัยที่มีอิทธิพลมากในสาขา quantum computing เกือบทันทีที่เผยแพร่
วิทยานิพนธ์โดยรวมของงานนี้คือคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมที่ noisy ให้ผลลัพธ์หรือ expectation value ที่แม่นยำ
โดยใช้ 127 qubit และ 2,880 gate เกินความสามารถของ Brute
Force ซึ่งเป็นการจำลองแม่นยำของ quantum circuit ที่ hardware execute งานนี้
สำคัญด้วยเพราะแสดงว่าคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมสามารถใช้ยืนยันหรือเปรียบเทียบผลกับ
วิธีแบบคลาสสิกโดยประมาณสำหรับ quantum simulation เช่น tensor network algorithm ที่ไม่รู้
คำตอบล่วงหน้า สิ่งที่ cool มากก็คือตอนนี้คนอื่น ๆ ที่ใช้ IBM quantum system บน
cloud และ Qiskit สามารถทำซ้ำและยืนยันผลลัพธ์เหล่านี้ด้วยตัวเอง
ฉันจะแนะนำวิธีทำแบบนั้น สำหรับตัวอย่างนี้ เราจะเจาะจงมากขึ้นเกี่ยวกับ
ขั้นตอนที่เกี่ยวข้องในการ map ปัญหานี้เป็น input ที่ quantum device เข้าใจได้ ในกรณีนี้ เราจะ
จำลอง dynamics ของ total magnetization ของระบบ magnetic dipole spin บน lattice ใน
การมีอยู่ของสนามแม่เหล็กภายนอก ระบบสามารถอธิบายได้ด้วย Ising model ที่มี transverse magnetic field
เราสร้างแบบจำลองนี้ด้วย parameterized quantum circuit ที่ parameter สอดคล้องกับค่าที่ปรับได้ของ
spin-spin หรือ Z interaction และความแรงของ magnetic field X
ซีรีส์นี้ชื่อ quantum computing in practice ดังนั้นเราจะพูดถึงกระบวนการในการทดลองนี้ด้วย
เพื่อให้ผลลัพธ์ดีที่สุด ถัดไปจะพูดถึงวิธีลบ
qubit ที่ไม่ดีหรือ qubit ที่มี gate fidelity ต่ำหรือ decoherence time สั้น ซึ่งอาจส่งผลกระทบอย่างมากต่อ
ผลการทดลอง qubit ที่ไม่ดีเหล่านี้อาจเกิดจาก calibration ที่ไม่ดีก่อนหน้า
หรือ two-level system ที่โต้ตอบกับ qubit การลบ qubit บางตัวออกจาก hardware native topology สอดคล้องกับ
การพิจารณาระบบบน lattice ที่อธิบายโดย topology ที่ได้ เรายังจะพูดถึงการสร้าง
parameterized quantum circuit ที่ implement time evolution ของระบบผ่าน trotterization
สำหรับจุดประสงค์นี้ สำคัญที่ต้องระบุ entangling layer ซึ่งเป็นส่วนสำคัญสำหรับเทคนิค error
mitigation หลักที่เราจะใช้ในภายหลัง ดังนั้นในตอนนี้ฉันต้องการให้คุณผู้ชมรู้ว่า
คุณสามารถติดตามทุกอย่างที่ฉันกำลังจะพูดถึงในบทเรียนที่ลิงก์ไว้ด้านล่างและบน IBM
quantum learning platform ในบทเรียนนี้ สิ่งที่คุณอาจสังเกตได้คือเราสร้าง helper function
ชุดหนึ่งในตอนต้น notebook ที่เราสามารถเรียกใช้ภายหลังเพื่อทำให้ชีวิตง่ายขึ้น ฉันอยากพูดถึงสิ่งเหล่านี้
ตอนนี้ ไม่ใช่เพราะมันเป็นส่วนของกระบวนการทางการหรือเป็นทางการ แต่เพราะนี่คือสิ่งที่นักทดลองมักทำ
ในชีวิตจริงเพื่อช่วยรันการทดลองประเภทนี้ และยังแสดงวิธีที่เราจะแบ่งย่อย
ปัญหาของเราต่อไป function ที่เรานิยามใน notebook มีดังนี้ Remove qubit couplings
Define qubit couplings, Construct the layer couplings, Construct entangling layers และสุดท้าย Define trotterized
circuit ถัดไป มาพูดถึง layer coupling ซึ่งช่วยนิยามว่า qubit
โต้ตอบกับเพื่อนบ้านอย่างไรระหว่างการจำลอง quantum device ของเราใช้สิ่งที่เรียกว่า heavy hexagonal
layout รูปแบบพิเศษสำหรับการเชื่อมต่อ qubit ใน layout นี้ เราสามารถจัดกลุ่ม connection ที่เรียกว่า edge เป็นสาม
ชุดแยก ที่ไม่มี connection สองตัวในชุดเดียวกันที่ share qubit นี่
สำคัญเพราะบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมจริง เราไม่สามารถรัน two qubit gate พร้อมกันถ้ามันเกี่ยวข้องกับ
qubit เดียวกัน แต่ละ qubit มีส่วนร่วมในแค่ gate เดียวในแต่ละครั้ง โดย
แบ่ง connection ทั้งหมดออกเป็นสาม layer เราสามารถ apply two qubit gate ทั่วทั้งอุปกรณ์ในสาม
รอบ โดยแน่ใจว่าไม่มี qubit ใดถูกใช้ใน gate มากกว่าหนึ่ง gate ต่อ layer gate
เหล่านี้ implement ZZ interaction จาก Ising model และถูกทำซ้ำในแต่ละขั้นตอนของการจำลองที่เรียกว่า
Trotter step Twirling ปรับ noise ในอุปกรณ์เพื่อให้แม้แต่ noise model ง่าย ๆ
ก็น่าจะแม่นยำ นี่ยังทำให้สามารถเรียนรู้ noise model ได้อย่างแม่นยำและใช้ข้อมูลที่ได้
ใน error mitigation technique
ถัดไป เราต้องลบ qubit ที่ไม่ดีออกจาก physical qubit ที่เราสามารถใช้ใน
การทดลอง อย่างที่บอก qubit อาจกลายเป็นไม่ดีด้วยเหตุผลหลายอย่าง บางครั้งเป็นแค่
calibration ที่ไม่ดี ความผิดพลาดง่าย ๆ ที่แก้ได้ด้วยการ calibrate ใหม่
บางครั้งซับซ้อนกว่าและเกี่ยวข้องกับสิ่งที่เราเรียกว่า TLS ซึ่งเป็น two-level interfacial
defect ที่นำไปสู่ qubit parameter fluctuation และ relaxation สามารถ
แก้ได้โดยอุ่นระบบทั้งหมดขึ้นเล็กน้อยแล้วทำให้เย็นลง แต่ใช้เวลาสักพักและทำผ่านคลาวด์ไม่ได้
ดังนั้นตอนนี้สิ่งที่ง่ายที่สุดคือแค่ยกเว้นพวกมันจาก list ของ physical
qubit ที่เราจะใช้ คุณสามารถระบุ qubit ที่ทำงานผิดปกติได้ง่ายจาก IBM quantum platform
คุณสามารถ plot คุณสมบัติ qubit ที่นั่นบน platform หรือดาวน์โหลดเป็น CSV แล้วสร้าง list ของ
qubit ทั้งหมดที่ต้องการยกเว้นและลบพวกมันออกจาก list ของ physical qubit ทั้งหมดบนอุปกรณ์
โอเค ตอนนี้ต่อกับ mapping step ของเรา โดยสร้าง trotterized circuit เช่นที่แสดงก่อน
trotterization จะ discretize time evolution เป็นชุดขั้นตอน และเราต้องตัดสินใจว่าจะกี่ขั้น
เราจะเลือกหกที่นี่ แต่โดยทั่วไป strategy คือการสมดุลสิ่งที่เรียกว่า Trotter error ซึ่งเป็น
algorithmic approximation error กับ error ที่เกิดจาก decoherence Trotter step มากขึ้นลด approximation
error แต่ต้องใช้ quantum circuit ที่ลึกขึ้นซึ่งมี decoherence noise มากขึ้น เราจะนิยาม
circuit ในรูปของ theta parameter ซึ่งเป็นความแรงของ external magnetic field, layer coupling และ
จำนวน step และ qubit และแน่นอน device backend เนื่องจาก
magnetization ของระบบขึ้นอยู่กับความแรงของ external magnetic field มันน่าสนใจที่จะ
execute การจำลองที่ค่าต่าง ๆ ของความแรงสนามแม่เหล็ก ซึ่งแปลงเป็นมุม RX ต่าง ๆ บน
rotation สำหรับ RX ใน circuit ตอนนี้ที่สร้าง circuit แล้ว เราไปที่ optimization กัน
ขั้นตอนแรกคือนิยาม pass manager จำไว้ว่าในบริบทของ Qiskit SDK, transpilation หมายถึง
กระบวนการแปลง input circuit ให้อยู่ในรูปแบบที่เหมาะสำหรับ execute บน quantum device
Transpilation มักเกิดขึ้นในลำดับขั้นตอนที่เรียกว่า transpiler pass pass manager คือ object ที่
เก็บ list ของ transpiler pass และสามารถ execute บน circuit ได้ สร้าง pass manager โดย initialize pass
manager object ด้วย list ของ transpiler pass ในที่สุด pass manager ของเรา
จะสร้าง ISA circuit ซึ่งเป็น circuit ที่ต้องเขียนในรูปของ backend's instruction set architecture
ที่อธิบาย circuit และ gate ที่ native ต่อ backend แต่ขาดข้อมูล timing ที่ต้องการรัน
circuit ตอนนี้เราพร้อม execute circuit ซึ่งเป็นขั้นตอนที่สามของ Qiskit patterns ดังที่บอกก่อน เรา
จะใช้ estimator เป็น primitive ที่เลือกสำหรับการทดลองนี้ เพราะต้องการวัด total
magnetization ของระบบ และการ estimate expectation value ของ observable คือสิ่งที่ estimator ถูกออกแบบมาสำหรับ
ในขั้นตอนนี้ยังสำคัญมากที่ต้องระบุ option สำหรับ error mitigation เราจะใช้ zero noise
extrapolation เพื่อให้ได้ผลลัพธ์ที่ดีที่สุด โดยเฉพาะในบทเรียน คุณจะเห็นว่าเราระบุค่า noise factor
สองค่าขึ้นไปสำหรับ evaluate extrapolated model และระบุ
probabilistic error amplification เป็น amplification option
Probabilistic error amplification หรือ PEA จริง ๆ เป็นเทคนิค error mitigation ที่เลือกใช้ที่นี่เพราะมัน scale ได้ดีกว่า
ตัวเลือกอื่น ๆ มาก และนั่นคือสิ่งสำคัญเมื่อเราทำงานในระดับ qubit มากกว่า 100
สุดท้ายแต่สำคัญ รันการทดลองและจะใช้เวลาสักพัก แต่ตอนนี้ มาอ้างอิงข้อมูล
ที่ queued และเก็บไว้จากบทเรียน เราจะตรวจสอบ metadata โดยสังเกตเป็นพิเศษถึง layered gate และ
mitigated layer เนื่องจากเราใกล้จะใช้สิ่งเหล่านั้นเพื่อลบ error จำนวนมากจากข้อมูล raw เราเกือบพร้อม
plot ผลลัพธ์สุดท้ายแล้ว แต่ก่อนนั้น มาเพิ่ม interlude เล็กน้อยที่นี่เกี่ยวกับสิ่งที่ zero
noise extrapolation หรือ ZNE หมายความว่าอย่างไร เราพูดถึงมันสั้น ๆ ในตอนก่อน แต่เพื่อทบทวน zero noise extrapolation
เป็นเทคนิค error mitigation ที่ลบผลของ noise ที่ไม่รู้จักระหว่าง circuit execution ที่สามารถ
scale ด้วยวิธีที่ทราบ มันสมมติว่า expectation value scale ตาม noise ด้วย function ที่ทราบที่แสดงที่นี่ ซึ่ง
lambda parameter ระบุความแรงของ noise และสามารถถูก amplify ได้ เราสามารถ implement ZNE ด้วยขั้นตอนดังนี้
อย่างแรก amplify circuit noise สำหรับหลาย noise factor ได้แก่ lambda 1, lambda 2,
lambda 3 และอื่น ๆ รัน noise-amplified circuit ทุกตัวเพื่อวัด
expectation value a ของ lambda 1, a ของ lambda 2 และอื่น ๆ แล้ว extrapolate กลับไปยัง zero noise
limit ซึ่งเป็น expectation value a ของ zero
ความท้าทายหลักในการ implement ZNE ให้สำเร็จคือมี noise model ที่แม่นยำสำหรับ expectation value
และ amplify noise ด้วยวิธีที่ทราบ
มีสามวิธีทั่วไปที่ error amplification ถูก implement สำหรับ ZNE ได้แก่ scale pulse duration ผ่าน calibration
repeat gate ใน identity cycle และเพิ่ม noise ผ่าน sampling Pauli channel
เราเรียกอย่างหลังว่า PEA Probabilistic error amplification เป็นทางเลือกที่ดีที่สุดที่นี่เพราะ pulse stretching มีต้นทุน
การคำนวณสูงมาก Gate folding ขาดการรับประกันทางทฤษฎีในการรักษา noise bias แต่ PEA สามารถ
apply กับ circuit ใดก็ได้ที่รันด้วย native noise factor แต่ต้องเรียนรู้ noise model PEA สมมติ
ว่ามี layer-based noise model เช่นเดียวกับ probabilistic error cancellation
อย่างไรก็ตาม มันหลีกเลี่ยง sampling overhead ที่ scale แบบ exponential ตาม circuit noise เพื่อเรียนรู้ noise model
เราต้องระบุ layer ที่ unique ของ two qubit operation ใน circuit ก่อน
สำหรับแต่ละ layer Pauli twirl two qubit gate เพื่อให้แน่ใจว่า noise อธิบายได้ดีด้วย Pauli noise model
repeat identity pair ของ layer ที่ depth ที่ต่าง ๆ กัน และสุดท้าย fit fidelity หรือ error สำหรับแต่ละ noise channel และ
แน่นอน แม้ฉันแนะนำให้เข้าใจวิธีนี้ในระดับหนึ่ง แต่การทำมือใน Qiskit
ง่ายกว่ามากอย่างที่แสดงในบทเรียน ตอนนี้สุดท้าย มาดูข้อมูลที่ plot แล้ว เส้น
สีเทาประแสดงผลลัพธ์แม่นยำที่ได้จากวิธีแบบคลาสสิกโดยประมาณ โดยมี approximation error
converge ไปยัง threshold ต่ำ อย่างที่เห็น ข้อมูล raw สำหรับ noise factor ต่าง ๆ ที่เราเลือกตั้งแต่ต้น
ห่างจากเส้นประนี้มาก เส้นสีน้ำเงินทึบแสดงข้อมูลที่คำนึงถึง ZNE
ของเรา และคุณจะเห็นได้ทันทีว่ามันใกล้ผลลัพธ์แม่นยำมากขึ้น
โดยสรุป ค่า noisy แสดงการเบี่ยงเบนสูงจากค่าแม่นยำ ค่า
mitigated ใกล้กับค่าแม่นยำ แสดงประโยชน์ของเทคนิค mitigation ที่ใช้ PEA
และนั่นก็จบตอนนี้โดยพื้นฐาน สรุปสิ่งที่เราเรียนรู้ quantum simulation เป็นหนึ่งใน
พื้นที่แอปพลิเคชันที่มีแนวโน้มมากที่สุดในระยะสั้นถึงกลาง
มีการประยุกต์ใช้ในวงกว้างตั้งแต่ยาไปจนถึง high energy physics,
material science และอื่น ๆ Utility paper จาก IBM ที่เผยแพร่ในปี 2023 ชี้
ทางสู่การใช้คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมสำหรับการค้นพบทางวิทยาศาสตร์ และเราดำเนิน
บทเรียนที่เกี่ยวข้องกับงานวิจัยนั้นอย่างละเอียด ขั้นตอนสำหรับจัดการปัญหาการจำลองตั้งแต่ต้นจน
จบค่อนข้างตรงไปตรงมา โดยเฉพาะเมื่อคุณคุ้นเคย และหวังว่าคุณ
สามารถใช้วิดีโอและบทเรียนนี้เป็นแนวทางสำหรับปัญหาการจำลองอื่น ๆ ในอนาคต
ขอบคุณที่ดู และเจอกันครั้งหน้าใน Quantum Computing in Practice